all this goes on and Merlin just sits
there over dude Doctor Who review time
we are up to midnight but before we get
to talk to it I get to tell you that
this video is sponsored by radio versus
the Martians it is a podcast hosted by
Mike Gillis and Casey Doran where they
discuss all manner of geeky material
from akira
to Batman to watchman to world wrestling
to the entire cinematic over of arnold
schwarzenegger podcast LaVista baby is a
sub series on the same podcast feed it's
incredible all things great they have
amazing guests great topics good
discussions it's the McLaughlin group
for nerves radio versus the Martians at
Radio versus the Martians calm or
wherever you get your podcasts midnight
oh this one huh if you haven't rewatched
this since seeing it the first time you
need to cuz there I think there are a
few episodes that flat-out benefit from
a rewatch the way this does there's a
few there's this blink there's some
others but I mean and that's not to say
that other Doctor Who episodes aren't
worth rewatching of course now if you
enjoy we watch it whenever you want but
I mean like you get you catch more
because you it there every performance
of every character in this you can just
any given view you just choose to focus
on them and learn more about that
specific character and get a little bit
more out of it
this is oh so good there's so much that
I love about this so okay we've got our
bottle episode the doctor on this tour
bus effectively on an uninhabited planet
that is beautiful but dead
when the bus breaks down and something
we don't know what there's not supposed
to be able to be anything alive out
there on the surface of this planet but
something gets inside kind of it doesn't
physically enter but it appears to take
over one of the passengers and that
passenger starts repeating the other
passengers and everybody just starts to
unravel not knowing what's going on not
knowing why not knowing what it's
pointing towards and just to watch the
whole thing just crumble ice oh good it
is so good and like there's so much I
love about this first of all I look I'm
just gonna refer to it as the midnight
entity because that's what I think but
as I love that we don't know what it is
how it operates what its goal is whether
this is just a simple survival mechanism
or some part of a grander plan we know
nothing and we shouldn't because now the
air other characters know they're flying
blinded so are we so is the doctor and
he has that little twinkle in his eye
encountering some leaves never seen
before which ultimately that's something
that will bite him in the butt
later on and I love that the way that
this entity operates it turns the doctor
with this specific incarnation of the
doctor specifically it turns his
greatest asset against him his voice I
mean the doctor you know always has been
always has great lines is always good at
talking himself out of things are buying
time or whatever but Tennant really did
that a lot I would say more than any
other doctor before him really just
would talk his way out of a situation
whether he convinced somebody to do
something different than what they were
about to do or whether he just stalled
for time his
mouth was his greatest weapon and here
it is used against him his mouth every
time he speaks it gives this thing more
power and his attempts to calm the
situation with his words backfires when
his frustration builds and he bursts out
at them because I'm clever and they're
all just oh you think that little of us
just took that one moment of anger which
is another thing that tenant has a bit
more than most doctors and it just turns
turns against em it's such a perfectly
constructed villain for not just the
doctor but this specific incarnation of
the doctor I might even go so far as to
say this is the absolute perfect enemy
for tenants doctor not the doctor in
general but him specifically this is
perfect because he's powerless against
this thing it's it's so good and and
like I said every performance is great I
had a lot of fun focusing on all the
other characters this time watching I
pay particular attention to the hostess
who we never learned the name of and she
was interesting because of all the
passengers on there starting out she is
in a very unenviable position because
she has to toe the company line and
reassure them with a script that she
probably has like if cost if the
passengers seem unsettled say these
things so that's what she's doing and it
doesn't help but when she abandons the
script when she when she realizes the
cockpit is gone and that like the rules
as she had been trying to operate under
don't like that good clearly are out the
window now she actually is the strongest
strength of her convictions and which
makes things interesting because she's
the first one she is the first one
to suggest that they throw sky who is
possessed by this entity out of the
vehicle and into the deadly Sun she's
the first one to suggest it when the
doctor basically calls their bluff said
would you throw me out as well she's the
first one to go if we have to she has a
lot of strength in her convictions once
she realizes that she can't just fall
back on what the rules are and she has
to figure out what's going on herself
and but then that's not just twisted
into something evil because it's that
same strength of her convictions that
makes her the only one who acts when the
doctors about to get thrown out even
though there are at least one conflicted
and two other people who flat-out
believe that the doctor should not be
thrown out but she's the only one who
acts because she's got the strength of
her convictions and we saw that go in a
darker out before but then it becomes a
heroic thing at the end I love all that
and then watching the the insecurities
of the other characters you have the
professor played by Patrick Troughton
son and he looks and sounds a little bit
like him at times too which is kind of
cool but you can see his insecurity when
his student threatens to know more than
him about what's going on he slams her
down because that's a threat to him the
father of this little three-person
family the instant he feels like his
masculinity or his bravery is being
called into question he starts to
bluster and puff and just it just brings
out the worst as he tries to prove that
no I'm I'm a take-charge guy really and
you know his wife who I'm not gonna go
so far as the same man manipulates him
because that because she's very much
operating on panic um so man
manipulation sounds like it's all
calculated I don't think it is she's
operating on raw panic but she's also
pushing
to be the one to do things she doesn't
want to get her hands dirty with this
and then there's their son Jethro who
you know is is more laid-back in this
kind of paying attention but then by the
end is just overwhelmed he's too young
he's still young and he's taking in too
much and he doesn't know how to cope
anymore by the time it's done and
somewhat similarly the the student she
you know she she feels like she's right
but she also feels powerless so she's
watching this they're about to throw the
doctor on she knows it's wrong but she
feels powerless to stop it these are all
such wonderfully rounded performances
fully developed characters and I've said
before that usually you need a
two-parter to get feel like you have a
fully fleshed out supporting cast but
they do it here a single episode these
all are such fully fleshed out
characters brilliantly performed I feel
like they don't feel like plot mechanics
they don't feel like gears turning the
levers of the story they feel like
people with history both before and
after this and we're just seeing a
window into this one thing that they
experienced it's just this thing's
phenomenal and and like how unsettling
the repeating thing is it's so simple I
mean like but my daughter does that she
still does like still does that on
occasion she'll get in the mood you just
repeat what I say it's so simple and
basic and childish but turned into
something terrifying and then the little
shifts when it catches up and it's
simultaneous and then when she gets
ahead of him that is that's a
heart-stopping moment when that happens
even when you know it's coming it's like
oh god oh
hahaha I love the tension
I love the breakdown I love that the
doctor does what he always does you know
tries to calm people down talks to his
opponent his enemy you know the the
alien force that's causing harm to try
and figure out what's going he does what
he always does but this time it does not
work cuz it can't because his skill set
isn't gonna save him or anybody not this
time it is a masterful piece of work to
the point that like I don't I don't want
this sound belittling like I didn't know
Russell T Davies had it in him but like
this type of story I wouldn't have
thought this of him based off his other
output in the show and I enjoy a lot of
his writing but this is this is a whole
other level this is so experimental but
tight it's not loose it's not meandering
it knows exactly what it's doing is it
is fine-tuned it is refined to a razor's
edge this thing oh it's so good I just I
don't that a lot but it just is it's
phenomenal and I love it even more now
like I already loved a lot but like
revisiting again like oh yeah oh yes all
the yes
Midnight's oh boy rankings series 4 is
going to be hard when I get to the end
of this thing this is gonna be up there
though midnight what do you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't just repeat other
people's comments
that's not unsettle everybody yeah but
there's also a whole bunch of other
stuff to do down there cuz there's the
lights which are big help people been
hitting it lately and I absolutely
appreciate it you can subscribe if you
are you can support me on patreon if you
want to help make
all of this better and help push me into
being able to do bigger and better
things with this there's other links to
things besides that I wrote a book
socials Pio box it's all down there
check it out but also you don't have to
because at the end of the day you're at
the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]